this is the wind bot seven it's a window
cleaning robot now here too yes you can
see a lot of fancy brilliant huge tvs i
just want to look outside and the wind
bought someone's going to help me do
that what it does it it sticks to your
window via suction it has tractor feet
so i can cruise around and has two
removable and washable little pads and a
little squeegee so you can get all that
extra water off once you place it on
there it just starts cleaning when it's
done it goes back to the original
position so you don't have to worry
about reaching across or being in a
weird position and if you're concerned
about the power going out and if falling
off don't worry it has a rechargeable
battery so it's cool for at least two
hours the way about seven is going to be
available about the spring and we're
looking about a 400 our price point